hello and welcome to the 9th PHP
tutorial in this tutorial we're going to
be discussing the while loop so with
that let's go ahead and get right into
it
the syntax for a while loop if you
remember the syntax for if statement
it's very similar you'll say wow Whaley
not really well and then you'll have
your parameters and then you'll have the
curly braces for action so with our
while loop let's go ahead and specify a
variable and we're just going to call
our variable X and we're say x equals 1
and then what we're going to do is say
Wow X is less than 10 we want to do
something what we're just going to do is
we're just going to count and make a
pretty simple counter so what we'll do
is we'll just echo X and then we'll just
do X plus equals 1 so we'll just keep
adding 1 to X until it is no longer less
than 10 and it's gonna print that out
every time so let's save that we'll run
it oh we've got to add our semicolon
here I'm just gonna keep doing it trying
to forget that as much as I can and
we'll just refresh and as you see we've
got 1 2 3 4 5 7 8 9 it's probably a
better way to do it is to an append a
quick break here
like that and then you'll probably get a
better sense of it if you haven't
already so there you go it's counting
you know one to nine basically through
this while loop and that's pretty much
what there is to the you while loops so
pretty basic in a quick tutorial there
for doing that in fact I think we've
done that so fast we could probably fit
in the regular for loop as well there's
also a for each loop that will touch on
probably in the next video I prefer the
for each loop but regardless the same
thing we can do we actually don't even
need it the X there so you kind of same
thing if you're from Python you can you
like specify the variable itself okay so
now the for loop the structure is very
similar you've got for something and
then you do something so we're going to
say for and we'll say counter and that
counter will just define it's equal to 5
then we're going to say the counter is
greater than or equal to 1 then we want
to do counter minus 1 so then in here
what we will do each time is we're just
going to echo counter and we'll echo a
break in here as well
save that putting up on the server well
refresh and turn out if we count five
four three two one so it's just another
way to make a loop and if you notice it
yeah it looks a little bit shorter and
quicker than the while loop but either
way so that's that with the while loop
in the for loop within PHP as always
thank you for watching